if you were in an airport on october 9th
you might have seen this
long queues and i mean really long
queues
southwest airlines which has been ranked
by wsj as one of america's best
performing airlines cancelled around 1
900 flights across the us in just one
weekend the initial disruption according
to southwest started on friday night in
florida with air traffic control issues
and disruptive weather but while most of
the airlines were back up and running on
saturday morning southwest was stuck in
turmoil for days when an airline gets
behind it it's hard to catch up so what
took southwest down well the company
like other airlines has been navigating
a difficult balancing act as it tries to
recover from the impacts of the
chronovirus pandemic and while some of
the issues the company faces may be
unique to south west others are faced by
the entire us aviation sector so as we
head towards the holidays does this mean
we're likely to see more cancellations
well to get a better idea i wanted to
know exactly what took down southwest
now if there's one person who knows it's
our aviation reporter alison cider she's
been covering the aviation sector
throughout the pandemic and if you've
been following her headlines you might
have seen this coming so here's what we
know
firstly southwest went into that weekend
with staffing levels that hadn't
recovered from the pandemic like most
airlines southwest had agreed to not
furlough or lay off staff during the
pandemic in exchange for access to
billions of dollars in aid but the
company did like many other airlines
offer employees early retirement or
extended leave as it tried to reduce
staffing costs they had you know about
5000 employees up to retire and 11 000
go on some kind of leave and you know
those leaves they might have been a
couple of months they might have been a
couple years but demand for flights
returned far quicker than many in the
industry anticipated and that left
airlines with a bit of a staffing crisis
they started calling everyone back who
was on leads and though some of those
staff did come back southwest is now in
a hiring spree the company says it aims
to hire some 5 000 people this year and
some 8 000 people next year but overall
in the industry there's a lot of
competition for pilots right now you
know their training takes a really long
time so it's not like you can just pick
someone up off the street
then there were the routes that south
west were flying that weekend or rather
the sheer number of them last fall
southwest embarked on a new strategy
they had planes that they weren't using
i'm still getting paid to keep all their
employees on staff so they have a lot of
employees who are underutilized and they
started looking at you know where could
we go to pick up more revenue you know
where might there be pockets of demand
that we could access and they embarked
on this very aggressive expansion plan
they announced 18 new cities you know
over the course of the year they weren't
alone towards the end of march there are
150 new domestic routes announced by
airlines but by the summer some airlines
began trimming back the number of
planned flights to alleviate potential
strains southwest was actually one of
those airlines in august the company
said it was trimming some of its routes
in order to catch up on hiring new staff
but on that sunday october 10th the day
of the cancellations southwest actually
had more flights planned than it had in
any day since april 13th 2020 that's
right at the start of the pandemic
but part of the reason friday night's
disruption affected southwest more than
any other carrier is due to how
southwest operates
see most operators run a hub and spoke
service where planes go from and return
to a central hub while southwest does
have some hubs the company mostly runs a
point-to-point system where its jets
continue their journey on to the next
airport the net impact of this is on
that weekend the pilots that south west
did have were scattered across a range
of rooms and according to their ceo when
the system was disrupted southwest
couldn't get its planes or its pilots to
where it needed them to be the only way
for southwest to fix the problem was to
have a full reset you know sometimes
they just need to rip off the band-aid
and cancel a lot of flights in order to
get
aircraft and people back where they need
to be to sort of start fresh
so what does this mean for the flights
going into the holidays well given that
most industries are facing staffing
problems as more u.s workers have quit
their job than at any point over the
past two decades the aviation industry
is unlikely to fix its staffing problems
overnight what airlines can do however
is fly less routes less often to ensure
that they have enough staff to go around
so for consumers less choice for a
thanksgiving flight may mean you have a
better chance of actually getting there
it probably goes without saying but if
you want to know more about the aviation
sector make sure you follow alice
insider i've left a link to her coverage
below and as always if you're interested
in the future of how we might be getting
from a to b then don't forget to
subscribe catch you later
[Music]